if you had to battle flesh eating
vampires what would you do you'll have
to battle an ancient organization and
fight a secret evil that won't stop
until it destroys the world I'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat Helsing
ultimate this police girl will turn into
a terrifying vampire and will be forced
to watch everyone around her die her
Squad responds to a freaky emergency
call in this small town announcing there
is something insane going on entering
this church they see this man tonguing
this severed corpse and then they get
surrounded by more bodies but they look
different firing their weapons they all
get overrun and scream and cheer Terror
meanwhile just outside of town the
police set up a perimeter but get a
visit from a strange lady who claims
she's from a British organization that
they've never heard of introducing
herself as Sir Integra Fairbrook she
says she is the director of the Helsing
organization and declares that this
sleepy small town has now become overrun
with ghouls the police look at her in
confusion and can concern and she gives
the lowdown of what's really going on
vampires exist and non-virgin humans
that are attacked by vampires turn into
their flesh-eating servants the police
chief can't believe what he's hearing
but Integra warns them that her
organization has been defending the
British crown for generations and if
they don't listen to her now this plague
will spread and millions more will die
this is her job the Servants of vampires
are called Ghouls and them being in this
town means there's a single vampire
hiding here somewhere and controlling
all of them then they get word on the
radio that all of their human forces
have been wiped out and Integra Smiles
telling them that her top anti-vampire
expert has already arrived meanwhile
deep into town the policewoman from
earlier tries running for her life she's
barely escaped death but gets surrounded
by blood thirsty ghouls before we
continue we want to give a shout out to
Tails and Dragons for sponsoring today's
episode tales and dragon's New Journey
is a free to play RPG set in a vast
fairy tale World strike the perfect
balance between work and play by
indulging in this idle game whenever you
want to unleash your imagination as the
chosen dreamer and embark on thrilling
adventures with fairy tale Heroes
discover a fun to play AFK game with a
super convenient idle system level up
effortlessly and score tons of rewards
without complex tests immerse yourself
completely in the game and say goodbye
to frustrating level Roblox nurture and
strategically combine Heroes for an
awesome journey of growth plan carefully
and create powerful hero combos to
unleash their full potential in battles
endless strategic fun awaits as you
explore various hero skills attributes
and gear options immerse yourself in a
Fantastical world of dragons and Magic
experience an incredible live
performance that brings fantasy fairy
tales to life join interactive
adventures with diverse fairy tale
characters and embark on an adrenaline
pumping quest to defeat dragons start
magically with 1001 free draws upon
login unveil over 100 captivating fairy
tale characters and collect rare Heroes
build a powerful team or complete your
Hero Collection with this amazing bonus
making leveling up a a breeze are you up
for the challenge get in on the action
and download the game now absolutely
free just click the link in the
description or scan the QR code on your
screen right now and for a limited time
enter the code tnd luck for 500 diamonds
and more worth thirty dollars now let's
get back to the video all right look
this is crazy that's why two survive I
would have relied on the terrible UK
police payment system that makes play
the time that cheddar by the way my good
weeps is actually a real place and it's
located in Somerset England however
sometimes things really don't make sense
over here because the average police
response time on average in City areas
is around 7 minutes but that can often
double to around 14 minutes so you know
give or take that being said the fact is
that these cops showing up and being as
surprised as they were was really really
strange because all of these vampire
zombies are located in one spot that
means that all of them were either
turned into flesh eating monsters at the
same time or they got turned elsewhere
and then all gathered in the church here
and even if this place is a nest turning
all of these people and moving them as a
horde into the church if you've ever
seen any zombie movie you know that
hordes a flesh eating monster typically
make a mess wherever they go and because
of this the cops due to their short
response time think they would have seen
something right these cops fell into the
classic move of shooting against the
horde of flesh eating monsters and not
running away just because it looks cool
type of crap I say screw that you're
only getting paid 23 to 28 000 pounds a
year have a different career because no
job is worth getting a bite-sized hole
in your face this vampire tells her that
oh she looks tasty and he'll make her
his servant for
eternity she looks death in the face and
screams just as this mysterious Man
shows up attracting everyone's attention
he tells this vampire that he is death
of the vampire who laughs and commands
his ghouls to kill the stranger firing
thousands of bullets The Stranger Falls
over but that's when the faint sound of
the Dead Man's laugh gets louder and
louder the moon above them turns blood
red as the dead man's body begins to
emit black smoke and he rises from the
floor fully regenerated and he whips out
his monster piece shocking this vampire
and all of the ghouls around them
getting obliterated in mere seconds this
vampire quickly realizes that this
stranger is carrying with him holy
ammunition and finally understands that
he is up against the one thing that can
defeat his kind another vampire but this
one's different panicking the bad guy
grabs the police girl and holds her
hostage in front of the red dressed
vampire but it smiles and asks police
girl if she's a virgin confused and in
shock she yells the word yes taking out
his gun he fires one round right through
her chest killing the vampire and her he
walks over to the dying woman and
apologizes for killing her and says that
she now has a choice to make she doesn't
have much time left and it's a choice
that's going to cost her her life or her
soul she reaches her hand out to him and
finally passes out a few days later the
police girl wakes up in the straight
room and sees her wound completely
healed and the mysterious man from
earlier right next to her well
scaring her and The Fearless killer
introduces himself as Alucard and
reveals to her that she has now become a
Dracula a female vampire she will now
outlive the sun live without daylight
and will be immortal for the most part
and be forced to feed on the blood of
millions she screams out in horror just
as Integra enters the room with her
Butler Walter they tell her that she is
now under the property of the Helsing
organization and a monster or not she
still better have manners and act like a
lady Integra tells her that they are a
branch of monsters really designed to
protect this country from other monsters
and she works for them now getting
suited up Alucard gives her her first
mission and throws her straight into the
fire heading to the Midlands to inspect
a new recent vampire attack tracking the
Rabid vampires to this small house I
look hard forcefully enters and fires
his big fatty right through this guy's
gray matter one of his henchmen tried to
run away and Alucard tells the police
girl it's now her time to shine aiming
her rifle in the general direction of
the running away vampire it's pitch
black without a scope she can't see
anything she does doesn't know what to
do but all the card columns are down and
coaches her to aim like a vampire
unlocking her night vision and she takes
the shot for bullet whizzing through the
air successfully killing this vampire
and completing her first mission Alucard
smiled and tells her that she still has
a long way to go until she reaches her
full potential later back at Helsing
headquarters Integra tries to analyze
all of the recent vampire ghoul attacks
that have happened around the country
because something strange is going on
the next day they get notified that
another vampire attack has happened but
this time it's somewhere where it's
never been before in a place that's
technically outside of their
jurisdiction Ireland suiting up Alucard
and police girl head on over there by
helicopter meanwhile back at Helsing
headquarters Integra suddenly gets word
from one of her spies that the Vatican
has sent someone to intercept Alucard
someone from the Special Operations unit
the 13th division Iscariot the vatican's
top soldiers an organization that on the
books doesn't exist within the Vatican
she quickly realizes who they sent and
tells Walter that they need to go and
save Alucard and police girl now back in
Ireland the two vampires land and do
what they do best kick ass and take
names there Alucard and police girl get
to work cleaning up the aftermath and he
teaches her some new vampire tricks and
she tries to lick her sweet kill off of
her but suddenly she gets stabbed in the
throat by someone's dagger shocking
Alucard he realizes it's a holy dagger
and suddenly senses that they are now
both trapped within a spiritual barrier
they can't go anywhere and he hears
incoming footsteps standing across from
him in the hallway this man tells a la
carte that he's heard a lot about him
and he is just like him he introduces
himself as Anderson and he claims that
he is from the Iscariot branch and is
the vatican's top Soldier and that this
is the first time a vampire ghoul attack
has happened on their land and as an
agent of God he will not let any
Protestants get in their way no filthy
monster will raid his land including
Alucard and the police girl okay this is
crazy but if I was them I would have
been way more prepared all you gotta do
is know some simple virginity ratios
predictable Catholic mindsets and some
good old zombie killing let me explain
Anderson here is the worst of the worst
and an absolute monster aside from his
insane fighting skills and being able to
use a Bible to teleport himself places I
mean I don't know what's more dangerous
about him this guy thinks his mission is
a holy Crusade his hatred towards the
Protestants for no reason except due to
his hatred of it and that shows us how
extreme he really is a la carte and his
organization should have known that
fighting vampires on land that is
technically not their territory just
invites problems and practically begs
the Catholic Church to waltz on in and
say hey what are you doing here because
look even if there wasn't a peace treaty
a la carte and his teams have the
capabilities to assume that Anderson
isn't bad crazy and would likely do
whatever it takes to take us down please
go here for example also should not have
followed along with Alucard she should
not have gone with him to that location
because if it takes a virgin hear me out
now to become a vampire most will just
turn into a ghoul for this reason I
would have made sure that she was way
more ready before she got into the field
because she is unprepared as hell I
would have first picked up some more
servants to join me on this Mission
having more helps means the job would
have gone done faster and we could have
left faster and possibly have been gone
before Anderson showed up Anderson
reassures the police girl that he didn't
strike any of her vital organs this will
be his first hunt in a while so he wants
to kind of draw it out and enjoy himself
he tells these two that he's already
killed the vampire in the village that
there's no need for these two to be on
his sacred land anymore him and Alucard
walk closer and closer together each
taking a really sick Sinister Delight
before forcibly locking Metals together
taking a good chunk out of both of them
but Alucard quickly finds out that
Anderson isn't a regular priest and he
doesn't die stabbing a la carte he
ignites his force field against his
bullets and charges right at him locking
him on the wall with his holy blades now
trapped Anderson reveals to him that he
is no ordinary human and that he has
been engineered to kill monsters like
him and he brutally chops off his Fred
in front of police girl and blesses his
kill with the words ah man he laughs at
helsing's greatest weapon and laughs
like a maniac but then he remembers that
oh whoops police girl has disappeared
giving him more time to enjoy the hunt
nearby police girl tries to escape tape
holding on to all the cards severed head
but quickly gets Shish kebabed by
Anderson who finds her and walks over to
her trapped in a holy barrier she then
hears alucard's voice his head melts and
forms a blood soaked letters on the
floor telling her to quickly drink his
blood so she can gain the full powers of
a vampire but she hesitates what and
it's too late Anderson approaches her
and is about to kill her when his weapon
gets shot by Integra who's just shown up
she warns him that he is in direct
violation of the Helsing and Vatican
peace agreement and that neither of
their branches can afford a crisis
between them right now he laughs and
calls her a filthy Protestant charging
at her swiftly killing both of her
guards and these two lock swords he
tells it that he already caught off the
head of their finest vampire Warrior and
says it's over she she laughs at him and
tells him that he's not really dead like
him and says that he has to do better
than that her family spent over 100
years trying to produce the finest
vampire that has ever existed just in a
swarm of bats burst through the window
regenerating Alucard instantly Anderson
tries to attack but quickly realizes
that he's not truly ready to take this
vampire down he tells them that he'll
get them next time using some holy magic
he disappears integer then tells these
two that he just violated their
organization's agreement because of this
the Vatican must pay them back but for
now they have to focus on the bigger
problem on the way over here she found
out that a huge organization is working
in the shadows they are the ones behind
this seemingly unorganized string of
vampire attacks and they need to deal
with that first Alucard asks police girl
why didn't she drink the blood but she
tells him that she would feel like she
would lose something important if she
did the group then heads back to
headquarters and police girl tells a la
carte that her name is Saras but he
doesn't care because well she looks like
a police girl so him she is now forever
police girl reaching back to Helsing
headquarters they hold a very important
meeting with the leaders of their
company planning their next steps and
have no idea that somewhere deep within
the Shadows a horrifying Army is
preparing to declare a terrifying
Supernatural war on Britain and the
world Integra tells everybody in the
meeting that she finally found a lead on
the cause behind the vampire attacks she
says she found this on all of the
vampires they've killed it monitors
their Vital Signs and also functions as
a camera and a microphone meaning these
vampire attacks have not been random at
all they're being led by someone they've
also realized something shocking usually
when there is an army of ghouls there is
one or two virgins in the group that get
turned into vampires this hasn't been
the case recently because even little
boys and girls have all turned into
ghouls as well before Anderson attacked
them he also told them that he already
killed the vampire way earlier but if
that's the case this means that the
ghouls in Ireland were being operated by
someone else someone who wasn't anywhere
near the battlefield Integra thinks
they're at war with something or someone
as good as them and with way more
resources that's when they hear a huge
Rumble from above on the ground floor of
their headquarters and they get shocking
news that vampires have infiltrated
their secret base getting word that
their forces are getting quickly
overwhelmed she tells them to buy time
while she signals for police girl in a
la carte and her Butler to come save
them and that's when they hear a knock
outside of their giant steel door by a
vampire he introduces himself as I'll
call him beanie guy and he tells him
that they're here to kill everyone at
this meeting meanwhile deep in the sound
proof basement of headquarters Walter
gets into a fight with police girl and
says that since she is not drinking
blood sleeping in a coffin will be the
only thing that can prevent her from
losing her vampire strength she finds it
super creepy and it's at that time when
Integra called them on the phone and
tells them what's going on upstairs they
must try to stop these two vampires
since they can't wait for backup to
arrive in time Walter and her create the
game plan they'll split into two teams
using the air ventilation shaft for
police girl and Walter to enter the
conference room to provide support while
Alucard deals with well everything else
including the second vampire headed down
here alright this is crazy that's why in
order to save everybody here and win
this situation I'm going to pack
everybody into one room tighter than a
pack of sardines let me explain Helsing
Manor is the best organization and
located on London's outskirts and guided
by some of the best men what doesn't
makes sense here is how weak their
security is I mean seriously these guys
just showed up at the front gate and
completely overrun the place you would
think that this organization deals with
some of the most dangerous threats in
the world they would have had at least
oh I don't know a more fortified base
because they're dealing with a lot of
super strong tough enemies in this
business I could go on forever about
this for one they had a lack of sensors
around the base they had no cameras
presence as well as they only had two
manned security at the front entrance
for comparison's sake MI6 the security
description has been reported to having
everything from security cameras
reinforced bomb and bulletproof walls
triple glazed glass to block electronic
access and jamming and the majority of
the building being freaking underground
partially covered by a moat but Hellsing
manner on the other hand allowed a squad
of soldiers to break through the front
gates with a simple firearm they went
right through the front door and no one
really noticed until they were already
inside as British Top Monster hunting
agency that they would have been better
funded and would have been able to
better defend themselves from a bunch of
enemies that effectively most of them
are just run-of-the-mill soldiers based
on the principle of Arkham's law which
states it usually simplest explanation
requires the fewest assumptions and is
usually right this means that it makes
sense to assume that these people here
are here to take out or abduct the top
dogs of this organization Integra a la
carte and all of these dudes around this
table which means don't split up this is
the worst thing that you could do keep
your freaking Ace in the whole a card
with you at all times and go to the
conference room Integris man try to hold
off the vampires and ghoul Army but it's
a bloodbath with the last human
slaughtered except the ones in the room
beanie guy tells his brother that
they've cleared the entire headquarters
and oh it was so easy and that's when
his brother this blonde guy heads down
into the basement to find alukar and
that's when beanie guy sees a man step
out in front of him an old man Walter
and suddenly a string of light Zips past
instantly cutting his army down in half
Walter than formally introduces himself
as the Butler and a former vampire
Hunter and he brings his old man moves
out of retirement and disposes of even
more ghouls hordes more monsters try to
overpower him and he signals for police
girl across the hall to take the shot
firing round breaking up the ranks and
weakening the bad guy ice forces
panicking beanie guy tries to escape but
gets caught by police girl and the two
interrogate him finding out that he was
sent here to attack the Helsing
headquarters and kill their greatest
weapon Alucard someone more powerful
than they could ever imagine is behind
all of this and he summons a second
surprise Army overwhelming these two
while he tries to reach the conference
room Walter failing to stop him he busts
through the doors but Integra welcomes
him to helsink they all blow him down
back underground blonde the vampire
enters alucard's room and sees him
sitting down relaxed and he tells
Alucard that he is his biggest fan and
is really honored to brutally Slaughter
him they both draw their weapons and
fire off around Alucard quickly realizes
that this Blondie is more powerful than
ordinary vampires and finds out this
monster and his brother were designed by
somebody to take him down realizing he
needs to use more power Alucard then
releases control system levels 3 2 and
1. and announces to blind guy that he's
just been given approval to use his full
power on him for limited time of course
and he unveils a new kind of Horror
buying power the room suddenly goes
black as oligarch summons these demon
dogs to attack blonde guy and he quickly
finds out that he is no match for
alucard's Powers he tries to run away
but gets his legs blown off forcing this
lone little vampire to stare at the true
vampire King horrified he calls Alucard
a monster and this pisses him off and he
sends his Devil Dogs to consume this
guy's soul I love it back upstairs the
remaining ghoul's overpowered police
girl forcing her to accidentally unleash
more of her vampire powers shocking
Integra and she quickly runs to check on
her telling her to bury her monster back
inside of her almost dead Walter asks
beanie guy who sent him but beanie guy
tells him that the chips they put inside
of him means his boss already knows
what's going on and will never let him
talk this was all part of an experiment
and that's when his body sets on fire he
flips him off and yells the words Beware
of the Millennium and he kicks the
bucket this word captures everybody's
interest and they figure out that it
must relate to what could very well be
going on they get to work trying to
decipher what it could mean the next day
Walter updates Integra that saw far that
Millennium that they found Jack Potter
apologizes to Integra and tells her that
at this point they only have the word to
go off of a now dead vampire but this
could also mean a period of a thousand
years and that's when Integra notices
something and figures out something
incredible and thinks that this word is
similar to the Millennium Empire that
their country fought half a century ago
which has then led to a really rather
sort of famous mustache man and his
famous Army but they don't realize that
this famous haircut Army has already
begun their terrifying World experiment
a few days later the Helsing
organization hires ruthless mercenaries
to gather at their headquarters because
they now know that a war is coming and
they need to get ready quickly Integra
then reveals what their real Mission
will be they will be fighting vampires
and will be equipped with the tools to
kill them these mercenaries look at her
a little bit confused and think she's
crazy forcing her to reveal to them that
her organization is working with the
British Empire to keep vampires a secret
from society and shows them proof police
girl The Mercenaries laugh and this guy
walks over to her instantly getting
flicks back by the this five foot little
tiny girl that has the strength of 20
men shocking them and just then Alucard
also pays them a visit through this wall
terrifying everybody here and Integra
tells them that they will be hired also
to protect him while he sleeps Walter
then bursts in and announces that an
important letter has arrived from the
leader of the vatican's most feared
fighting force Iscariot Enrico Maxwell
she heads on over to meet with the
leader of the organization showing up in
neutral territory this public museum
meeting with this man Maxwell he tells
her he didn't come to England to fight
but after what happened with Anderson in
Ireland she doesn't trust him and he
gets annoyed and tells her that the pope
has sent him personally to deliver
something whether she likes it or not
the tension in the room forces on the
card to appear and warns this guy that
if he keeps disrespecting her he'll kill
him right here Maxwell smiled and
reveals his own bodyguard in the man
they met earlier Anderson showing up and
ready to kill the two Alphas come at
each other and are unable to keep their
cool forcing both sides to tell them to
chill out sheesh and just then police
Crow comes in and saves the day dragged
Along by these two innocent Museum
visitors everyone now calm Anderson and
Alucard to leave while Maxwell and
Integra talk business outside he tells
her that the Vatican has found out what
she already knows they have a common
enemy of hiding in the shadows and his
organization has found some information
on them he hands her a file revealing to
her that 50 years ago after World War II
the remaining supporters of mustache man
fled to South America and that place has
now become a stronghold for them
suspicious Integra asks him how the
Vatican knows about this and he says
that well because they helped them
escape and set up the New Millennium bad
guys group shocking Integra but he
reassures her that this was years ago
way back in the old days totally not
recent at all okay now look this might
not seem believable and really crazy
information but this actually can be all
explained through Catholic immigration
and economic recession let me explain
after World War II thousands of Germans
used Escape Routes out of Germany that
became known as rat lines and mainly LED
towards Havens in South America as well
as the United States and Switzerland as
well these Escape rooms were supported
by some clergy of the Catholic church
since part of the Escape Routes did
route to Eng Rome through Rome and
because of this relations between places
in South America and Rome were already
set up before World War II which also is
going to help expand Catholic
immigration to the world and the
craziest part about all of this is that
the world already knew about this since
1946. according to the Secretary of
State he said that the amount of Nazis
using these red lines to escape was
negligible and the pope at the time also
basically didn't see this as much of an
issue either he preferred to see fascist
war criminals on board ships sailing to
the new world rather than seeing them
rotting in POW camps in Germany Integra
and Maxwell continue to talk not
realizing that they're being watched by
these two mustache loving men and their
leader later Integra tells Alucard that
his team is headed south to Rio De
Janeiro but not to party but to go and
find out more information about the
Millennium group figure out their
mission and well Search and Destroy
flying down there they reach their hotel
and get ready for their mission that
night police girl is woken up by a la
carte and tells her that something
strange is going on to turn off the TV
and find out that well their hotel is
now surrounded by Rio's entire police
team led by this guy this Mr tuber Clan
Latin mustache looking guy and he
announces that they killed a few
innocent people at this hotel which is
total BS Integra suddenly gets updated
by what's going on with her team and
find out that the Vatican hasn't really
learned their lesson from last time and
are now trying to mess with them again
down in Brazil she worries that Alucard
will kill everybody there because she is
not down there to stop him back in Rio
Hollow card laughs and gets ready to
brutally Slaughter everybody here in
order to reach his objective the police
soon surround the top floor and have
Alucard cornered approaching the
entrance they bust in and see Alucard
they open fire and blast him to bits but
his body quickly regenerates instantly
coming back to life and he lunges at the
police biting all of their heads off and
this one last survivor gets so scared
that he decides to leave permanently
police girl then comes out of hiding
shocked at how many humans a la carte
has killed he notices her shock and
tells Earth that she needs to focus on
the job then receives a call from
Integra asking uh well what's up
happening we all good you haven't killed
everybody right right and he says he
slaughtered all of them and he tells her
that no matter what he does she is the
one that ultimately must pull the
trigger she hesitates for a sec and
almost shows some Humanity then steadies
herself and tells him to focus and to
kill everything and anyone that gets in
the way of their plan impressing even
Walter Alucard then busts out of the
hotel room meeting the rest of the
police force and killing dozens More
Humans making the police girl scared and
alerting the rest of the city's police
forces outside and everybody is
completely unaware that someone is
watching him through this monitor
telling his people that he's impressing
him and he orders Mr tuber Clan to
attack meanwhile a la carte continues to
feed on the police going down the lift
he burst through the front Hotel door
and litters the street flagpoles with
dead bodies and he's having so much fun
and he announces his powers impressing
even the mysterious glasses guy secretly
watching him and just then Mr tuber Clan
reveals what's really going on and tells
a la carte that the man who tried to
attack him were all promised the elixir
of life if they managed to defeat him
because this entire continent loves what
the mustache loving man stand for and he
reveals a bunch of flying cards and
shoots them at Alucard and these two
battle it out in front of the rest of
the police Alucard tries to retreat to
the roof to catch his breath for a hot
SEC and realizes that the card that hurt
him is preventing him from regenerating
somehow and that's when the police chief
shows up again and Strikes police girl
also shows up and helps Alucard out
creating smoke in the air allowing
oligarch to sneak up behind him breaking
his foot and shooting his hand right
through his entire body and winning this
Death Match wasting no time he drinks
his enemy's blood and figures out
everything he knows the mustache man
want to go to war with the world and
have created a new stronger vampire Army
and just then this dead vampire's body
burns up as one of helsing's mercenaries
rescues them on a helicopter and they
escape to a hidden location to catch
their breath all the while glasses guy
watches it all from afar his minions get
a little bit sad that they lost the
battle but this glasses guy is delighted
since they've learned so much about
alucard's powers and his 50 years of
hard work is about to pay off ordering
them to head back home his entire Army
of Skye Zeppelins Plato course head
straight for England glasses guy's Army
quickly reaches this mustache loving
location to meet with the big boss of
this whole thing but here glasses guy
then reveals something that only a few
people in his organization knows they
reveal that Hitler trusted him for his
top secret Nazi plan and they will use
their new Army of invincible vampires to
take over the world the boss guy is
shocked at this twist and glasses guy
tells him that well he's no longer in
charge he is and gets knocked on the
floor beating him up the boss tries to
force glasses guy to finally turn their
mustache loving kind into vampires like
they agreed upon because he's the only
one that knows how but then he suddenly
gets stopped by this vampire and these
men and everybody surrounding this old
boss turns on him major glasses guy then
declares himself as the new boss again
of this evil group and announces that he
will start a war with the entire world
back in England Integra calls a la carte
and tells his men and his Squad to get
back to England now and realize that
escaping this mustache loving country
will be harder than they thought and
just then Anderson tracks them down and
bursts through their room and he tell
tells them that the Vatican has provided
them with a pardon letter and safe
passage to get back to England safely
finally arriving back in England Alucard
and his team meet with the queen he
approaches her and she tells him that
he's never aged a day since the last
time she saw him and he reciprocates
with some really cheeky vampire flirting
it's pretty cool and there iscariot's
the highest ranking leader in Rico
Maxwell shows up he then reports what's
actually going on and who glasses guy
really is to everyone 55 years ago after
World War II his people attempted to
create a vampire Army but him and young
Walter stopped him but they refused to
give up and have returned with their new
and improved Army and Millennium is
their last battalion but then suddenly
this little kid German vampire
interrupts their conversation putting
everyone on edge and sticking him up but
the German kid says that he's just here
to give a message putting a TV on this
table the kid quickly checks out police
girl and says glutenpag and then gets
back to turning on this TV and reveals
who is on the other side of this call
major glasses guy and he Reveals His
horrifying plan showing everybody that
he's gone mad with power killing the
rest of the Mustang party of his telling
everybody that he just wants to watch
the world burn showing that this guy is
loyal to no one but himself he declares
that his true enemy isn't the vatican's
Army but his enemy is Britain the
Helsing organization and Alucard having
heard enough they killed the boy and
shoot the TV and the queen then orders
them to destroy the mustache mess
meanwhile elsewhere major glasses guy
that heads down the basement and meets
with little kid vampire who literally
just got shot in the head and somehow
traveled thousands of miles away and
managed to reach back to glasses guy's
base somehow and the Germans then began
their Deuce ex machina plan they lift up
the entire German Fleet here and head
straight for England a little later
Anderson calls the leader of the
Iscariot Maxwell they talk about their
new change of plans to take revenge on
Helsing since the bad guys aren't
interested in them when the time is
right they'll destroy Helsing and the
mustache man when they aren't looking
the whole taking out two birds with one
stone type of scenario and Malcolm tells
Anderson that the pope himself has
reissued all of his troops from the
other branches to help the Iscariot win
this war once and for all preparing for
their next right righteous Crusade
against the vampires they must do
whatever it takes to win and kill many
monsters and humans that oppose their
reign the next day Helsing gets word
from the British government that they've
officially lost communication with their
Eagle aircraft carrier but the Royal
Navy can't reach it because it's now out
of their jurisdiction the government
says their men are trying to stop them
but Integra says it's already too late
and they get word that all the men they
sent have gotten murdered by one vampire
with a long-ranged weapon Integra tells
them that the ship is now run by
vampires which means it's their
jurisdiction and that means despite the
incoming Army sent to destroy England
she will stop everything she's doing and
will go to save that one random aircraft
far away from their main mission just
because gosh that is their biggest
mistake alright look if I was these guys
in order to save the world and outsmart
the bad guys I'm going to tape police
girl's chest let me explain isn't it a
little bit convenient that now within
the same time span of finding out that
these guys want to attack London but now
oh Loki here there's a boat just outside
of the jurisdiction of the British Navy
that it's super obvious that their
trying to set us up like we're the only
ones legally that can go and take care
of this situation and on top of that why
are we trying to save a boat in the
middle of the ocean for no reason other
than there's a vampire on it why would
you send your only trump card all the
card to go save this ship it is dumb as
hell and look glasses guy himself said
that he's going straight for the Helsing
organization and the British government
London which means they're probably
going to create some sort of diversion
like this a really obvious one of that
just like hot they did back in World War
II with the Blitzkrieg they would create
a diversion so then they could send
their Attack Force in and have them
encounter very little resistance because
why would you send oligarch your
greatest weapon to anywhere other than
London the Helsing organization's home
site I would go along with their plan to
make them think that we are being set up
but I'm actually going to take police
girl's chest way tighter than a
Victorian corset and make her look like
oligarch and then I'm gonna send her
with a bunch of dudes over onto that
boat make the bad guys think that a la
carte is there while a la carte is
actually with the Helsing organization
in London see not that hard Walter and
Integra figure out how to drop Alucard
onto the aircraft carrier using this
special military reconnaissance plane
piloting it all the card begins diving
from the sky at 85 000 feet above and
reaches Mark speed of 2.8 and charges
down below shocking all of these bad
guys including this vampire they try to
stop them but he crashes the plane down
into the ship like a madman setting
everything on fire arising from the
Flames he easily murders all of the
troops here forcing this vampire to
watch in horror she tries to duel him
using her magical rifle that never
misses but all the card easily stops it
quickly overpowers her feasting on her
flesh and major glasses guy watches it
all unfold through his cameras telling
everybody that she performed her Mission
perfectly with all the cards now trapped
at Sea major glasses guy gives his men
one last motivating speech telling them
how much he loves war death and screams
of his enemies and blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah while this guy's
nuts and he tells his 1000 vampire
strong Battalion that they better make
Daddy proud and his Zeppelin soon
reached the city of London forcing
everybody to watch helplessly including
Integra as they get ready to prepare for
the Bloodshed of millions soon to occur
so guys what do you think did you like
the video or didn't you like the video
let us know what you think about it
don't forget to like subscribe and leave
a comment down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how to be
playlist